s'aperçoit dans le diagnostic que 95%
des habitantes 50 ans l'idée pour des
déplacements moins 5 km utilise d'un
véhicule un diagnostic menée pendant
deux ans par l'agglomération en
collaboration notamment avec l' agence
locale de l'énergie et du climat lors du
conseil saint quentin en yvelines a
approuvé le plan climat air énergie
territorial c'est une vraie avancée et
mais finalement c'est surtout un
commencement
maintenant ce plan va être envoyée à
l'autorité environnementale qui ajoutera
aussi ces modifications qu'on sera
obligé de prendre en compte notre
objectif aujourd'hui de lancer ce plan à
partir de décembre 2018 pour commencer
la mise en application des fiches
actions des vingt-et-une fiches actions
à partir de 2019 et très progressivement
pendant six ans une plateforme
collaborative du nom d'esquimaux va être
mise en place
elle devrait voir le jour d'ici la fin
de l'année à l'ordre du jour aussi le
lancement d'un règlement local de
publicité intercommunale
il faut savoir que l'ensemble du rnb un
règlement on appelle
les enseignes et les frais en selle donc
c'est un lourd travail qui va s'engager
sur l'ensemble du territoire
près de 500 publicité et pré enseignes
ont été recensés sur le territoire saint
quentinois la volonté de l'agglomération
et de préserver les espaces naturels
l'environnement évidemment c'est le sens
du texte tout en garantissant aussi
l'activité économique puisqu'on a quand
même beaucoup de florent sur notre
territoire
donc voilà l'objectif c'est aussi
j'allais dire de faire un nettoyage qui
ont souhaité aussi s'attaquer aux
anneaux grands axes structurants qui
bordent aussi les centres commerciaux
les zones d'activités un règlement
unique sera établi pour le territoire
l'agglomération espère le voter avant la
fin de l'année 2019